ryan reeve suffered a brutal leg injury
last week during a preseason game and
all eyes are on his injury status here's
why everyone wants to see him in the
lineup on opening night i'm master here
with br open ice and today we're diving
into the rivalry of the rangers versus
the capitals the two are set to face off
on october 13th and this is shaping up
to be an absolute battle as you may or
may not know these teams they have some
history first let's talk about tom
wilson on may 3rd 2021 tom wilson caused
chaos bootsnevich was down on the ice in
the crease tom wilson comes from behind
and pounds his head into the ice as you
could probably imagine rangers players
did not take too kindly to that as our
temi panerai comes into the mix pulls
wilson off of buchnevich and then takes
him on himself our timmy panera one of
the best goal scorers and playmakers in
the league had absolutely no chance
eventually tom wilson ragdolls him
around the ice throws him down he hits
his head a couple times without a helmet
on it is just a terrible situation to
make matters worse tom wilson then heads
to the penalty box where he flexes
without a jersey on to the rangers bench
eventually resulting in him being kicked
out of the game this moment right here
changed the course of new york rangers
history the rangers ended up firing
their gm and president and now they're
on the hunt for a true enforcer that's
where ryan reeves comes in reeves is one
of the last remaining true enforcers in
the nhl in
686 career nhl games played he has
racked up
937 penalty minutes and only 49 goals
while you won't see a guy like reeves on
the scoreboard very often he can easily
turn the tides of a game with his energy
aggression and passion you have to keep
your head up or you're getting laid out
not only is reeves one of the toughest
enforcers in the league already he and
tom wilson they go way back in 2013 back
in wilson's rookie season after a big
hit wilson dropped the gloves with
threes and after a brief little
wrestling match did tackle him down to
the ice almost exactly a year later the
two would meet again and this one was
more than a wrestling match reeves would
connect on quite a few punches and drop
tom wilson over the course of the decade
ryan reeves would move from team to team
but the rivalry still lived on how can
we ever forget the viral video of reeves
dropping tom wilson twice in just eight
seconds there's some mutual respect
between the two and also some vicious
hatred and that's what makes this
rivalry so special these two teams met
in the playoffs four out of the last 10
years most notably in 2013 where king
lunk would shut the capitals out in game
six and seven to advance we can only
hope that reeves makes it into the
lineup on opening night but regardless
this will be a battle of the ages i'm
nasher here with br open ice let's see
what happens